hello London I guess I should say yes as
something said my name's Nick Radcliffe
I my second workshop for the day I'd
reprised TDD a which is a library will
be using actually during this
afternoon's session this morning I guess
at least one or two phases look familiar
and were probably there there'll be some
overlap but hopefully not too much and
what we're going to talk about is
anomaly detection I hope I set the level
of introductory it's certainly fairly
simple stuff though of course when I
submitted it I might not have known it
was going to be introductory so it might
not have been I don't know whether
people saw the various messages about
what you need to be able to follow along
there are various bits of software and
there were a couple of minor issues with
that hopefully you've all got numpy and
pandas anyway it's all going to go
better if you've got Python three than
Python two to a slightly greater extent
than I realized when I wrote this off
because it turns out the feather data
format that we'll be using is not
compatible between Python 2 and python 3
but a lot of the stuff will work in
Python 2 as well you'll need the TDD a
library all of these things are
available from PI pie with pip install
obviously resource versions available as
well the TDA library is available on
github you'll need the feather format
which again you can get with pip feather
who has heard of the feather format you
know a few hands not all that many
feather is a thing developed jointly by
Wes McKinney the author at the original
through pandas and the guy who's named
temporary is Casey Hadley Wycombe and
it's for interoperable data frames
between r and python and it's at least
supposed to be better than csv Xin sense
it carries some metadata around and
preserves precision on stuff like that
unfortunately it's a little bit broken
so you also need the pmmif format which
is now available
I apologize to anyone who tried
installing it and found it wasn't
available that was because it turns out
we'd never uploaded it to pi PI
and though it was available in source
from github but it's there now and in
case the text is small or you want to
refer to it later the slides are
available in the repo that you can clone
that has the data that we'll be using in
the all exercises examples whatever you
want to call the things we'll be doing
the TDA library does have documentation
and this blog TDA info so that's all the
introductory crap yep so what we're
going to do is I'm going to talk a
little bit to start with about the whole
notion of anomaly detection and try and
introduce you to what we're trying to do
I'm sure the general ideas will be
familiar to people and then we're
probably going to try building some
anomaly detectors by hand partly to show
that that can be quite unpleasant and
nasty and then we'll show you some
slightly easier ways to do it the
intention I'm sure we've got a spread of
expertise here and what I've tried to do
is to present kind of variant exercises
where if you're super sophisticated you
can do a much more complicated version
of it and if not so much you can just
read code or try running things and so
on and something else I was going to say
but I've forgotten what it was oh yeah
no something mentioned the the
background for this course is that we're
developing a course for data camp on
anomaly detection in Python data camp is
an online learning platform that you can
you can pay to do courses on they should
be released in
mm zoom ish and it's supposed to be a
four-hour online course where the
emphasis is very much on machine marking
of exercises and therefore the course is
slightly oriented towards typing and
programming as opposed to concepts which
I think are the really important thing
so I'm gonna try and stress the concepts
quite a lot because I actually think
that's that's the most important stuff
but in terms of the stuff you'll be
you'll be doing if you play along that
they'll they'll be a certain amount of
typing and Python and all that kind of
stuff so I guess I I partly apologize
for the fact this is the first time out
and the exercises haven't really been
tested and it's possible that there will
be anomalies in the exercises but of
course that's all just the in joke and
but partly you're very privileged to be
getting this before anyone else in the
whole universe if it turns out to be any
good wish you're getting it whether it
turns out to be good or not so a
normally detection obviously as the name
suggests and as you know anomaly
detection is about trying to find that
which is abnormal that which is a
deviation from what you expect and
probably the most important thing to
understand about it is there are no
right answers you can't tell from a pure
data but you can say from a statistical
perspective this value is awfully big or
something like that but without context
there's no such thing as there's no such
thing as obviously wrong data or even
the stuff that is obviously from a
statistical perspective wrong isn't
necessarily wrong in context if you
understand what's going on and so we're
very interested in typically we are
using anomaly detection to tackle some
kind of problem common industrial active
the word common applications are things
like detecting fraudulent credit card
transactions or any kind of kind of
fraud really systems failures noticing
when a server falls over or something
goes wrong
bogus e-commerce ratings people who are
trying to game the Amazon ratings or the
Netflix ratings or whatever medical
problems to take
heart arrhythmia you can formulate as as
an anomaly detection problem and indeed
almost anything that you would build an
ordinary predictive model for you can
typically reformulate as none as an
anomaly detection problem if you want so
if you talk about credit scoring you
could regard people who don't pay you
back as anomalous and then reformulate
the credit rating problem as can we find
those anomalous people who look like
that they're not going to pay us back so
it's it's it's it has very broad
applicability and almost always when
people talk about anomaly detection they
think about the negatives they think
about detecting bad things and that is
that is what we do mostly but it's also
the case that anomaly detection can be
very relevant to finding good things as
well as bad things if good things can be
anomalous so you know examples of that
would be things like spotting
interesting patterns in customer
behavior that you weren't expecting that
suggests opportunities so I'm sure
you've all heard the old sore about beer
and nappies at Walmart that they noticed
it's a it's a rather nasty sexist story
that I don't necessarily want to repeat
but it turned out that putting be near
nappies works quite well into in terms
of generating combined sales that was
something that supposedly and it's
probably in a urban myth was found by by
an automated data analysis process you
know more generally detecting I mean a
lot of what we're going to be talking
about with anomaly detection is actually
very very simple methods we're just
looking for in some cases things that
are out of range or things that are
missing or gaps in data and stuff like
that
it can be more sophisticated you can
throw the fanciest machine learning
system in if you want to to do various
kinds of detection but it will still
have to fit into some kind of context
like this to be useful as an anomaly
detection system we're not going to be
talking about the fancy methods at all
if anyone was here expecting me we're
going to have like four hour in the 90
minute session that would be ambitious
but 90 minutes of you know how to use
deep learning systems for anomaly
detection that's not what you're going
to get do feel free to free up your
seats and let some of the people who
haven't got seats leave if that's what
you were hoping for we're going to be
talking about a lot of very mundane
simple
anomaly detection stuff and the
frameworks that you need around these
things in order to do it so yes you know
other sorts of things detecting low
usage periods when you know maybe you
don't need the same level of servers or
the same amount of staff coverage or all
that kind of stuff are absolutely
anomaly detection problems as well I
should also say people should feel free
to shout if I am unclear or speaking
nonsense or making obvious mistakes it's
it's a workshop it's informal we can do
that I might not be able to see you
because I'm a bit blinded by the light
but if you shout loud enough all I'll
notice so let's just talk a little bit
about the kinds of things that we might
we might detect as anomalies some of the
sorts of things that we're looking for
are just outlying values of single
dimensions or single variables so you
know prices that are much too big or
successive events that are much too
close together if they're supposed to be
from a human and you're getting a
hundred thousand a second that's that's
you know not an ordinary kind of a human
sometimes you have to look at multiple
bodies so sometimes it's pair of values
that form an anomalous and unlikely
combined value even though the
individual values of both both perfectly
sensible my mind always tends to alcohol
you know the two-year-old who's drinking
an awful lot of beer or something would
be a kind of stupid example of that
patterns of regularity or irregularity
in data streams we tend to be very
interested in streams of data you can
you can find anomalies in any kind of
data but it's particularly streaming
data that we we tend to focus on
patterns of regularity can be a signal
that something's wrong or that there's a
gaming system or that there's there's
something you don't expect but it can
also be exactly what you expect this
back up going on at the same time every
morning then you'll probably see a spike
in your you know in your volume of
traffic when that when that backup hits
again it's all about context it's all
about understanding what you're looking
for and the job of the detectors is is
to the job the anomaly detectors in the
first instance is just to detect
anomalies however defined and then
there's a separate process of trying to
map anomalies
the cases where there are specific
things you're hoping to use the anomaly
detection to diagnose to map the
anomalies on to actual bad behavior or
good behavior or bad outcomes or
whatever it is you want defects or
actual fraud or whatever but just just
as in machine learning areas pile low
density and data can be interesting
again depend on whether they're expected
illegal data values more generally you
know nulls whether aren't allowed to be
nulls which or repeated values or stuff
like that so there's lots of lots of
simple things what do they look like you
know obviously there are there are cases
like these where very clearly that spike
looks anomalous without knowing anything
about the data and again from a sort of
pure data perspective it is anomalous
but whether it's bad whether it
corresponds to anything that shouldn't
be there or it's just telling you that
you know this is the advert and a lot of
people turn the cattles on when the
adverts start on in the middle of some
popular television series or something
you don't know you have to you have to
address it in the context of some given
circumstance and some interpretation
probably slightly clearer a hole in the
data like this would almost always be
wrong if you know if the volumes are
high but again not necessarily and even
if it is there are many different things
that could be causing it you know maybe
this is the transition from British
summertime or whatever and there
actually wasn't the 2 a.m. to 3 a.m. in
local time on morning the clocks went
forward and so from one perspective it's
anomaly and it's anomalous but it's not
necessarily indicating anything that's
wrong right again it always depends on
context and all of these diagrams are
much less extreme than than they
typically would be in fact when you see
a typical spike like this that actually
isn't normally what you really see is a
completely flat line with a spike
because the scale of the thing is is so
enormous that you can't see the rest of
the data and similarly you know we've
got a spike both ends of this
distribution but they're not actually
very fast in the center of the
distribution again in reality it's like
you've got all the good values are
between you know 2 & 3 and you've got a
minus 4 billion over here and a plus 16
trillion over here
and so again if you you know if you
actually look at it you'll see almost
nothing except the anomalies in the data
at least the most extreme anomalies in
the data so one of the things that often
confuses people with anomaly detection
is you know why do we need to automate
this stuff can't we just look at graphs
and the answer is well partly yes if you
can spot the stuff on graphs that's fine
even just plotting it on graphs and
seeing it can be very hard because of
the extremity of the nature of a lot of
the things that you detect as anomalies
but also in order to benefit from
graphical approaches you have to have
someone looking at the stuff and so
obviously a lot of the idea with
knowledge detection is to automate it so
that there are alert based systems
trigger based systems and you get into
all the problems of over alerting and
getting the balance right between really
detecting the things that you want and
not not having lots of false positives
but automating these processes even if
you can spot them graphically even if
you have a representation is still
typically very useful so as an example
this is this is some price data this is
real price data that we it's been very
slightly disguised but essentially real
price data that that we took from a
client it's about 15 million records and
if you do the simple histogram showing
prices it looks like the plot on the
Left
right so everything unaccountably is
between zero and $20,000 these are
actually airline prices but for some
reason the scale goes all the way up 260
180,000 or so and that's because there's
an outlier there that's in the wrong
currency in fact they're a bunch of
outliers the push thing you can't see
them you can't see them at all on the
graph but they're there and in fact you
sort of can't see them where you can't
see them because they're too low because
obviously on the scale of the graph
they're much less than a pixel high so
there are many things we can do about
that we can use nonlinear bins is one
technique but a very powerful thing to
do there's extra lines in that middle
graph are but a very powerful thing to
do is to use log scales
I guess everyone will be familiar with
the concept of locks you might not be
familiar with actually using log and
log-log plots so in in the middle graph
what we've done is we've taken that same
data and we've made the x-axis
logarithmic and as a result we've got
bins that go from well technically a
tenth of a penny to a pound a pound to
ten pounds 10 pounds to 100 pounds and
so on and you see that most of the data
plausibly for flights is between 100 and
a thousand pounds but you actually see
that you actually start to see what's
going on but in terms of the outliers
you can't really see anything outside
those three middle bins because although
we've log adjusted the X scale we
haven't logger adjusted height so you
can't see any of the small numbers so on
the right hand graph we've done a form
of log log plot where we're now plotting
the heights of the bars logarithmic ly
as well and therefore I see people
nodding our poetess rule the people for
whom this is very obvious I can
guarantee there are people who haven't
seen this sort of thing before so so now
having just both of them onto log scales
we can now see that there are about 10
things in this 1 million pound plus
flight and I don't about you but that's
more than I typically think Ryan as
worth and so forth so these sorts of
very simple transformations are helpful
and even if you are using automated
systems it's still typically very useful
to plot things so knowing about these
these sorts of techniques which which
were available in pretty much all the
major plotting libraries is useful
here's another example what I was
talking about with pairs of values
obviously these are concerned with
single values or single streams of
values here's an example where on the
Left we've got the vast bulk of the data
is lying on this this line in the middle
but and again this is this is the
opposite of exaggerated it's very
compressed compared with what it would
probably look like in reality but we've
got a couple of severely off diagonal
points where almost certainly we've got
we would describe those and as anomalous
and they may or may not be incorrect but
they certainly do
or here's another you know fairly
typical thing where we've got one point
or some collection of points sitting way
out on the on the right individually
those values are not that old but in
combination they're very old and here's
what I was talking about regularity and
so you know question is of course well
you know I thought this is this is a
week's worth of data we've obviously got
a spike at a similar time each day more
or less so you know are those do those
just represent back up processes or
something or or a time when everyone
gets home from work or whatever or is
there something wrong even if there is
something wrong what about the missing
one on sort of Friday night Saturday
morning it certainly looks like there's
something odd but knowing what it is is
something you're gonna have to dive into
in order to to actually find it so what
we're looking for with anomaly detection
is systems that will help us identify
these points these sorts of points and
do something with them alert us to them
or whatever so fundamentally spits
hopefully most of it out on the left
saying not anomalous obviously we hope
that most of our data isn't isn't a
muscle or in real trouble but
occasionally spits out one or two of
them and says this one's worth looking
at we're not necessarily looking for
them all to represent whatever it is
we're trying to detect but we certainly
want to narrow it down as much as
possible and hopefully have a high
proportion of the true Bad's or the true
goods or whatever it is we're looking
for on the right and so then very much
in the same way as in ordinary machine
learning sort of supervised learning
context if we have got something if
we're if we're doing a medical test for
example and we're you know we're
screening for cancer or something then
we in reality you know either the
patients have cancer or the particular
counsel we're looking for or they don't
or the disease or whatever it is or the
item is defective the idea is that the
ones I've colored in are truly defective
and we're doing some kind of anomaly
that we hope is correlated in a strong
way with identifying two active items
and what we hope is that the anomaly
detector is going to spit out a lot of
the defective ones or all of the
defective ones and very few or none of
the non defective ones so the non
defective ones are going to go left and
the defective ones are going to go right
and of course in the standard
terminology we call the ones that that
get detected positives and ones that
don't get detective as negatives and so
we have the concepts the concepts of
true and false positives with the true
positives being the ones that we detect
as being anomalous that are in fact
effective in this case the false
positives being the ones that get
detected but arms in fact truly
defective the true negatives is being
the ones that aren't defective and don't
get flagged by the system and the false
negatives as being the the ones that are
defective but that come out the wrong
side of the detector very often when we
build detection systems we'll actually
not just build a binary classifier but
we'll build some kind of a score we'll
have some level of confidence or ranking
or something to say how likely something
is and work will actually put a cutoff
on that score to determine which side
you know whether to classify something
as as anomalous or not and what we'd
like with our idea of course is
and that would be ideal
what in practice of course normally
happens is is that it's not like that
are false positive rate doesn't go from
doesn't step up like that it steps up
like this as we adjust the cutoff and
sure obviously if we cut off here then
we're saying we're not going to mark
anything defective so we're not going to
get any false positives but we're also
moving yet true positives we cut off all
the way over here we're not going to get
any we're going to detect everything and
we're going so we're going to defect
detect all of the true positives but
we're also going to to flag everything
else and so that's not good and the
trick is to try and find a good point in
the middle where our systems are
actually mostly doing the right thing I
wasn't sure about whether to include
this but people very often get very very
confused by false positive and false
negative rates and because I'm a
mathematician I thought we'd have one
slightly mathematical exercise that you
don't have to do but if you want to you
could so the way these things are
normally to find is that the false
positive rate is the proportion and it's
it's easier in the words action from the
proportion non defective items that get
flagged as anomalous and the false
negative rate is the proportion of
defective items that get flagged as
non-anomalous okay so it's the two
misclassifications and so if you're keen
and I would encourage you to be keen
it's interesting just to work through
and look at a fairly typical example
where maybe we have 10,000 items and 1
percent of them are defective I want to
scent of them are true part are truly
positive and 99 percent of them are true
negatives and we have a detector that
flags 80 percent of the defective items
as anomalous and 10 percent of the non
defective items as positive so if you
would like to accept the challenge fill
in the four boxes with the numbers that
are going to come through on average in
expectation confirm that the false
positive and the false negative rates
are twenty and ten percent
it looks like they should be and then
the really interesting bit the bit that
everyone gets wrong is calculate given
these numbers and guess first actual
would be a really interesting thing what
proportion of the items flagged by the
detector are actually true positives so
I'm gonna encourage you this you're
allowed to use computers it's fine
you're allowed to use mental arithmetic
there will not be a test it's just for
you but it's in trade I think I think
it's just about worth doing I think you
will get something out of it you might
be surprised by the results in the
context of medical tests
this makes you feel like back in school
doing - don't wear a dress with no
latest code
also if you've got the slights the
answers are on the next slide but
obviously
you haven't calculated it yet really
think about what you expect the answer
speak to the last bit because then that
starts to the customers don't trust me
okay in the interests of earning my
enormous presenters fee that the
organizers haven't haven't told me about
yet but I'm sure it's gonna be fantastic
I should probably move on and talk
through some of the stuff so the numbers
are nice I screwed it up which is which
is more than possible one percent or
eighty percent of one percent of ten
thousand is eighty so that's not true
positives the remaining twenty percent
is twenty we get 990 false positives and
eight hundred eight thousand nine
hundred and ten true negatives as we
expect the false positive rate comes out
at ten percent that's kind of obvious
and the false negative rate of twenty
percent the thing that tends to shock
people is that this means that only
seven and a half percent of the things
like weather detector are actually true
positives and so in a medical context
the thing that typically shocks people
is this means if you have a test that
you know has these rates that what that
will mark eighty percent of people with
the disease as positive and one percent
and 10 percent of people without the
disease is positive you've actually got
a ninety two and a half percent chance
of not having the disease disease even
when you get a positive test result back
and what this emphasizes is you really
need to be careful about where your
cutoff rate so because it's very easy to
get swamped with false positives if you
are too aggressive about making sure you
don't miss some positives depending on
how good your detector is obviously and
clearly so you know the solution for any
of you thinks it's better tests but we
can't always produce those so any
questions or shall we move on I promise
that's the end of the real man's real
maths the real summers so in general
what happens of course is that as if we
do have a sort of cutoff based system as
we
as we increase the cutoff false-positive
rate goes down but the false negative
rate goes up and the key is try and find
a good place it's not that's really a
point where that things crossover it all
depends on the relative cost of a false
positive and false negative if it's
incredibly important that you do detect
almost all the positives then obviously
you have to accept a higher false
positive rate model to achieve that
system still use even even the system
we've talked about here that looks
pretty horrible when you say only
southern half cent of the things that
came through actually were true
positives it's still the case that it's
allowed you to look at only 1070 or
10,000 and detect seven-and-a-half
percent rate against a one percent
background rate so it's you know you're
still getting significant benefit out of
the system
okay so one dimensional normal detection
here is an example of a transaction
stream which is the so we have one or
more identifiers we typically have some
kind of descriptive or categorization
information so you know if it's a
supermarket and you're buying items you
know what kind of item is what the Shelf
it came from that kind of thing what
what the size is that kind of stuff if
it's a phone bill you know is it a
long-distance or a local call as an
international as a detects messages at
data whatever typically some kinds of
numeric quantification price being an
obvious one but can be any of these
things potentially a bunch of other
things but they're typically fairly
narrow tables and we're looking for the
anomalous items so in this case we've
got an ID field that's an integer and
the constraints so so we're going to
that one of the simple approaches or
anomalous action is to define
constraints and to find things that fail
the constraints
as possible anomalies so here we're
interested in so we're gonna say the ID
shouldn't be null that's almost always
the case in a panda's context that's it
shouldn't be shouldn't be a man
IDs these are transaction IDs so they
ought to be unique in the table if we
get repetition something's gone wrong so
we wanted to take that as an anomaly
there are only five legal categories a
ACB cutie ka and TB and price field
should be non-negative and no more than
a thousand pounds it's pricing still
linked for these items so and this is
obviously a very synthetic example but a
huge amount of an organization will have
fundamentally these sorts of properties
there might be other data types you may
be using dates as what dates would be a
very common thing to have on here
actually and again in updates it takes
before 1970 or a complete no go in the
UNIX world because dates in 1970 are
almost always anomalous and so forth so
yes and as I discovered yesterday it
turns out that so there are feather if
you want succeed in downloading the
stuff from github there is an example of
this data that you can actually work
with in feather files if you is anyone
here actually using Python - rather than
Python 3 today no no it's not a shaming
exercise so if you are using Python 2
what you should do is if you've got the
github repo you should rename the data
file folder data 3 and you should rename
data to data and then everything will
work fine for you the stuff in the data
folder is Python 3 feather files and it
turns out that if you get some really
good anomalies if you read those in
Python 2 you get huge negative values
and huge positive values for prices even
once that I didn't didn't put into the
data okay so now we have a more
interesting set of exercises and we have
four different possible versions of the
exercise if you are relatively
experienced with pandas and with
doing this kind of stuff then you can
get the data with those two lines there
from detect assume you've got detect on
your path
make sure the detect file is somewhere
on your Python path import get 2d
outlier data from I suspect it should be
one D data outlier frame but I didn't
know that when I wrote it and that will
that will get you the data and your goal
is just to detect all the things that
fail fail these constraints if you are
reasonably experienced with Python and
have done a little bit with pandas but
I'm not super confident about it then
instead start editing exercise one dot
pi where there are templates for doing
each of the five four or five bits of
this and you can basically there are
little things saying fill in at various
points where you can put in the actual
detection functionality for different
kinds of data there is also a file
called hints dot text that has helpful
little hints in order for the various
exercises to with various Princeton so
you how to do them there are some
commented out far lines at the end of
the thing calling things in sequence so
if you're uncomment the first one it
will fail to run because there's a fill
in you you fill in the fill in bit and
it should detect stuff for you if you
are really pretty new to Python and
haven't done much of this stuff before
then start off by just running to tech
PI which is a work solution that
undoubtedly one hundred percent
correctly detects all the anomalies in
this data unless it doesn't read through
the code and try to understand how it
works and then point out the errors to
me and if you're even more expert than
than the experts you know how to do this
stuff look at detect dot pi and tell me
all the things I've done wrong and all
the things I've done in efficient and
all the things that you would have done
much better and will improve it for the
data camp people I am going to give you
a good good sort of 10-15 minutes to do
this I will wander around attempting to
help people not that I will probably
succeed happy to take questions and so
forth
the solutions are on the sides as well
so people have download
them it's easier on sites there are
copies on the slides
let me stick out on the challenge
[Music]
yeah
yes yeah I'm sorry attack the people
mama is in one bin subdirectory and
okay I think I'm tempted to carry on
them but how people and I'm sure most of
you won't have had time to do everything
yet but obviously you know you've got
the stuff so you can do it afterwards
people happy to carry on or would you
rather have another five minutes to get
a bit further I'm tempted to attempt it
to carry on the met the mean the mean
obviously for people who haven't done
this stuff before hopefully the sample
code is useful and hopefully you know
you're getting a feeling for what's
involved in doing this it's all
conceptually simple stuff but actually
doing some of these things like finding
duplicates detecting value is creating
new columns to represent those things is
is slightly painful in encode in pandas
so what we're going to do is look at
some slightly easier ways of doing
things hopefully I'm not going to go
through the sample code hopefully it's
relatively self-explanatory so what we
are going to is looking at is look at
making all this stuff simply using the
TGA library now Tilley a stands for
test-driven data analysis and the the
general concept behind test-driven data
analysis is to borrow some of the ideas
from test-driven development to try to
make data analysis work more robustly
and some of that's to do with providing
extensions to both unit tests and PI
tests to make it easier to write tests
for analytical processes where maybe we
can't just write the correct answer
beforehand because maybe the correct
answer is a million numbers or a graph
or maybe it's different every time but
has nice statistical properties or
whatever and so there's a lot of stuff
for what we call reference testing in
the library to do with writing these
kind of sets but the other part of it is
to do with checking data and the idea is
that it's for checking input data output
data and intermediate results the you
produced to make sure that your codes
doing what you thought on the data you
developed the system with and for
checking new data as it comes in and
that the results that you're producing
are valid but this turns out to be
incredibly useful for anomaly detection
as well which is
which is why it's used in this context
so hopefully you've all succeeded in if
you're if you're working along pip
installing the TGA library so this is
what I have just said so yes the part of
it we're going to be looking at is the
functionality for verifying data against
constraints which is pretty much what
we're doing with the anomaly detection
so far automatically discovering
constraints from good data and actually
running detection of bad data using the
library so going back to our example the
idea is that all of these constraints
are quite simple constraints that we
could express in for example Jason in a
format like this so this format which
the TDD a library understands we just
have a dictionary with fields in it a
key for each field and then a set of
constraints on each data and there are
six or eight different kinds of
constraints that the system understands
it understands type constraint which is
useful to put in anyway so it knows
what's going on with the field though it
doesn't have to be there we can specify
the and then to represent the
constraints we've got here we first of
all have a max knowledge constraint that
says the maximum number of nulls were
allowed in this field is 0 usually that
would either not be present at all or
we'd have this constraint in some cases
it's not that uncommon for there to be
systems in which you're allowed a single
null in a column but only a single one
representing a kind of other value or
something so so by having max nulls we
can actually specify a number that's
allowed but typically we set that at 0
we don't put the constraint in no
duplicates true means that we're not
allowed repetition in the column so the
two constraints that we have that it
shouldn't be null and that it should be
unique are represented there
the for string fields again in this case
we're saying it shouldn't be null and
that there are only these five values
that are allowed we can also specify one
or more regular expressions
that fields that string fields ought to
satisfy and the system will detect those
as well and for numeric fields and for
date fields we can put mins and maxes in
for Strings we can also put mins and
maxes for the length of strings in and
so in this case we're saying that the
minimum allowed value is 0 the maximum
allowed values a thousand and we're not
allowed any noise so that file
constraints dot T DDA is present
somewhere in probably in the 1d
directory that you've already got and if
you have installed everything
successfully then we're doing the detect
first okay well there are two different
things
actually what this is going to show you
is one of that tract detect that's
that's right is is is using that file to
find the records that violate the
constraints in the data that we've
gotten to spit out that data so when you
install the TDD a library installs the
TDD a command and the TDA command has
three variants
three main variants T da da discover
which is used to construct constraints
files from data we'll look at that in a
minute
tgd a verify which is used to check a
set of data or mass against a set of
constraints and tdd a detect which is
used to actually find the records that
violate the constraints in the file and
spit them out so if you say TD da detect
and then give it the input file which
can either be a CSV file as long as it's
in a suitable format that pandas
understands with the the slightly more
sensible than default settings that we
use which are detailed I think on the
next slide and then give it the name of
a suitable JSON file with those
constraints in so in this case
constraints EDD a and then tell it where
you'd like the bad records to go to
which again can be a further file or a
CSV file that will cause the bad records
to get spat out into bad CSV if you
don't put any more flags on it will just
spit out
the record number and the number of
constraints that failed for the records
that fail but you can if you say per
constraint it will actually spit out a
separate column for each constraint that
has any failures telling you which
records failed which constraints if you
say - - output fields it will include
all the input fields as well as the
output fields so you can see the full
record or you can give it a list of
fields that you do once about in the
output and you can also say there's an
option whose name I've forgotten to say
I want the good record spat out as well
and they'll get zeros for the number of
failures if you actually want to kind of
classify the whole file rather than just
acting in advance so if you run that
command and then look at bad CSV you
should find the very same set of Records
as detect produced and the very same set
of records that you produced if you in
the very large amount of time I gave you
succeeded in constructing your own
anomaly detectors to detect all that
stuff a few minutes ago so I will try
that he says
so here is the stuff and if I say tdg a
detect my input data which is data show
terms feather and my constraints file
which is constraints DDD a and the
output file that I want which is bad
stock CSV and I say mine
put fields and I say - something else
Oh detect bookends trapper constraint
hopefully that will tell me that six of
my constraints passed forward and failed
and hopefully that batts file has a time
very like now 14 23 and it has 33 lines
a net which the ones that fail for some
reason with tristan forces and all the
stuff so
so that's it is everyone succeeding with
that so this is this is this is quite
nice if you if you have a set of
constraints you want to apply and if
they fall into this sort of form you can
just write one of these JSON files by
hand and this will act as a
general-purpose anomaly detection system
in batch for you but of course writing
JSON files by hand is not an awful lot
of fun there's dam trailing commas that
don't work there's all the quotes and
stuff that are very painful and anyway
we hate doing that sort of stuff so the
second part of it is wouldn't it be nice
if rather than having to write the
constraints by hand you can actually get
the system to construct the constraints
for you so I think we also have we also
have so so the other idea with with TDD
a is that you can use to discover
command to construct a TDD a file for
you a constraints file for you that will
characterize a set of presumed good data
that you've given it so if if we run
that on the whole data set we typically
won't get a very useful set of
constraints because it you know it will
classify all the bad records as good as
well and therefore you know we won't ban
nulls and will allow crazy values in all
the rest of it but if we have some known
good subset of data then it will
generate the constraints for us that we
need even if we don't know which records
are good if we run it on the whole data
set we can then look at them and see
whether the constraints look sensible
and add the constraints that it should
have put in that it doesn't have and you
know either tighten or change the
constraints that that we would have
liked it to produce and that's a lot
less painful than constructing them by
hand so let's look at doing and of
course everything we're doing we can do
through the API as well so I've shown
you how to run it from the command line
but there are simple Python codes to do
all this stuff as well of course so
let's look at constructing one of those
TGA files from the good items
so how do we do that oh yes if you are
using it with CSV files these are these
are what system uses by default you'll
still have problems if you have empty
strings and nulls because that's very
difficult to represent in a way that
pandas CSV reader can can handle it
and there's the yes so there's the API
version of what we've just done as you
can see it's it's almost exactly the
same just with Python calls rather than
rather than command line calls
so let's now try and actually generate
the constraints file automatically and
the way we do that is using this
discover command
so if we see TDD a discover data slash
good item stock further good start TDD a
that will run over the good items which
are exactly the all but the 33 that
failed when we ran it just now we can
actually spit them out that way a good
stock TDD a then is that is the location
it will write the constraints file to
and we should get a file that's very
similar to the one we started with and
I'll talk about the second version of
the command afterwards so again if
people want to play along that would be
a good command to type auto cut and
paste if you're lazy
and so just give people a minute suitor
how does it know what's a good value and
what's a bad value and the answer is it
doesn't it assumes that everything that
you give it is valid so it will it will
generate constraints in almost all cases
that should be satisfied if you run a
verify or a detect on the data that you
generated the constraints from the whole
file should pass in almost all
circumstances there is another version
in so we have a commercial version of
the software as well as as part of our
mirror products which we're not
particularly holding back this
functionality just hasn't made it into
the open-source version yet and in that
commercial version you can give it mixed
good and bad data and it will do some
inference and try and work inference it
will it will use some heuristics to try
and work out what's like to be good data
and what's like to be bad data using
complicated rules like if there's only
one null well its differ only a couple
of nulls you know you know out of a
hundred thousand probably they're not
supposed to be there and stuff like that
you could give it hints about how much
of the data is liked to be bad and stuff
like that but in this case no it's just
very mechanically going through so you
know there's there's nothing complex
about it the minimum that it puts in is
the smallest value in the data the
maximum puts in it's the largest value
in the data it only says that there
aren't any nails if there aren't any
nulls the one exception being if there's
a single null it will say that the
maximum number of nulls is is one if
there are duplicates in the column it
won't generate and no duplicates
constrain it will generate every string
that's in the thing
though it does if it bothers to produce
a values constraint if there are more
than twenty or thirty or a hundred I
forget what the default is then it then
it assumes it's a non categorical field
and doesn't bother producing the
constraint okay so this is what I get
when I run it and obviously we get more
constraints than we had before we get
this exactly what I was talking about
this rather stupid constraint of you
know the minimum allowed value is so
there are a hundred million 546 which is
probably unlikely probably we want to
edit that and change it to a hundred
million I would guess and again probably
a maximum value of nine
99 899 is probably not sensible so we'd
probably either take that constraint off
or possibly cap it if we think it's only
supposed to have nine digits it's it
distinguishes it also puts in sign
constraints so obviously specifying the
min and the max does determine the range
of data that you're allowed but the idea
is that going fry if you had all
positive values before and sudden you
get a negative that's more significant
than than just the range changing and in
particular that if you do want to delete
the min of the Max constraint that
shouldn't necessarily remove the sign
constraint so we we sort of redundantly
code that you can see it's generated the
allowed values and it's generated more
or less what would want for price except
is obviously put in the maximum at 9 8 5
18 which is the maximum good value that
actually existed in the data we can make
them slightly more interesting by doing
the same generation but adding - - Rex
or is it - and I think - my friends and
what that does is gets it also for
string fields to try to generate regular
expressions so one of the clever things
that in fact the only really clever
thing in the library is it it constructs
a regular expressions from examples now
if you give it you know the works of
Shakespeare or something it's not going
to or good it's not going to do a good
job and it's going to take a very long
time but if you give it structured
identify as that are the sorts of things
you might actually want to use regular
expressions for then it will typically
do a fairly reasonable job they're not
always maximally tight or whatever but
it's it copes in quite a lot of cases
and so that's what I've done here and
obviously our regular expression is
going to be very simple in fact but what
we should see is as well as the explicit
around values of constraint we get its
notice that it's two letters in this
case and so dataset - which is a bit
easier than doing it by hand so that's
that's what you can do with the TDD a
library now obviously what you might be
thinking is well that's all very well
but
what if I want constraints that that
aren't the half-dozen kinds of things
that you can express within the TDA
library which is entirely valid what's
still helpful is the framework of the
GDD library so if you have extra
constraints that you want quite a
powerful with it there are a few things
that are very powerful to do in the
knowledge section one is just create new
columns in your data that codify what
you want so if you you know if rather
than having a min and the maximum you
have to two non overlapping ranges or
something you create a new column that
checks whether it's in that range that's
maybe just a binary column when you do a
discover on it hopefully if you've done
it on good data all of those will come
out as ones or zeros or trees or voices
or whatever it is so the constraint will
get added and you say well I did all
work what's the value of that the value
of that is that then you have a whole
load of columns like this as well as the
ones that can generate for you that can
then get checked and reported in the
same way so that you get the correct
indication of all the bad records
including including the ones that failed
simple constraints and the more
complicated ones and so those can be
things out of you know out of a neural
network or out of a classifier or
whatever the other thing that's very
powerful to do is to not just look at
the whole data set but look at different
subsets of the data set so it may be
that you know your read items have
different characteristics from the blue
items and that if you build separate
constraints files for those you'll get
much tighter constraints that are much
more useful and it's also very useful
often to use the thing on derive data
sets as well as the main data sets so
for example to aggregate you know to
count a number of things by various
items and then check that you you have
all the values that you expect that you
have the right ranges for those kinds of
things so it's not just a question of
simplicity throwing that at the primary
data set it's very much question of
using it for all the different bits and
pieces and going slightly beyond anomaly
detection in a more general data
analysis context it's incredibly useful
to check your input data with this to
character you know to check the data
you're getting matches the sorts of
constraints that you had on the data
that you develop the system with it's
check intermediate files and most
importantly to check output files
because you know we all talk about
garbage in garbage out the one thing
that's worse than garbage in
garbage out is his gold in garbage out
right you really don't want to be
producing analysis systems that take
perfectly good data and produce nonsense
from them and yeah that's what I'm sure
none of your systems do but occasionally
systems I have known and possibly have
been involved with producing candy no
not in the library obviously if you run
the discover process over it you can you
can sort of start to infer that again
our you know our software does that and
those sorts profiling things are very
common but no there's nothing in the
library itself to do that
good suggestion contributions always
accept not always accept it sometimes
accept it when they're really high
quality non-anomalous contributions but
again I'm sort of hoping that most
people have ways to some praising data
already and we're trying to add value in
places where it's more difficult okay
let's carry on any questions before we
move on or problems
good I'll take that as a good sign
we've seen that that that's the API
version of generating the same stuff
generalized seasonality yes I come from
Edinburgh where we have generalized
seasons a kid you know actually I am we
started probably no until recently paid
a to London was the only pay day to meet
up in in Britain and Edinburgh became
just about the second I think would just
be Bristol at least in terms of actually
getting the first meeting to happen
which was great we had about hundred
people at the first one in fact we had
more people turn up than had signed up
for the event which was pretty amazing
second one got snowed off being
Edinburgh because the building we were
supposed to be showing it in holding it
in was was closed but but if you are up
an Edinburgh do come to PI data
Edinburgh we'd love to see you so with
an awful lot of data an awful lot of the
data we see particularly in streams is
going to have some kind of a date stamp
on it and dates are every data
scientists favorite kind of data because
there's so much infinite variety in
formats in patterns in in ways of
counting things and obviously we're all
familiar with the idea that there are
regularities in the patterns of data
very often so you know there may be
different characteristic volumes are
different in different different months
of the year different seasons there can
be different patterns on different days
of the week characteristically different
times of day special dates that public
holidays can see quite different
patterns and so forth so there are lots
of things that we might need to adjust
and if we want to detect you know even
just unusual transaction volumes for
example that might indicate something
going wrong with a server or some kind
of a DDoS attack or some kind of a
gaming attack or something we kind of
have to know what the background is in
order to be and adjust for that in order
to be able to do this sensibly otherwise
we can only detect the most
in situations so adjusting for known
patterns in is very obviously an
important thing in the context of
seasons and in fact can be quite an
important thing more generally
relatedly if you're lucky enough to be
in a company that's growing or indeed
unlucky enough to be in a company that
you're thinking it may be the there's a
characteristic downward trend that you
need to adjust for or upward trend that
you need to adjust it all and so very
often we have to apply Corrections like
this so here is a fairly typical can't
read it but that's the 24 hours of a day
showing the volume of transactions for
something or other I think it's web
visits or something during a day and on
the right there's that very much the
same thing but over seven days where we
see there are different characteristic
volumes for different days of the week
as well and if we want to try and detect
problems with that if we don't adjust
for even even that level even where it's
just like a factor of 3 or 4 or 5 or 6
or Sat month five or six or something
from the peak to the trough we're not
we're not going to do a good job if we
don't adjust for that so we need to
normalize and so if we look at you know
a typical pattern so the idea is that
the the orange that you can't see at all
orange line on that is the the sort of
expected normalized behavior and the
blue is the actual and a couple of
points stand out very clearly you know
that peak definitely doesn't doesn't
look right and should get picked up by
almost all any anomaly detector and
similarly slightly less obviously but
but still pretty obviously that that
trough at zero looks very bad indeed if
nothing's fallen over if we want to so
you might hope at this point that
statistics would come to our rescue and
tell us where the outliers are but
unfortunately statistics doesn't really
help because sure we can calculate
standard deviations and things like that
and those will those will give us some
numbers to look for but typically our
data not only isn't normal in the
central limit theorem doesn't doesn't
really end up helping that much
typically it all becomes a question of
judgment and we have to decide again on
the false positive rate we want the
false negative rate we want how
sensitive we want systems to be so we
typically end up having to put bands
around our expected values when we
typically have to make two different
kinds of bands so one is we have to look
at some kind of proportion I think as
obviously very interested in how far
multiplicatively from from the value we
expect these things but we also
particularly for the low values need to
have some kind of an absolute thing so
that you know if we've got a very low
expected volume we're not going to take
one missing transaction as indicating
there's a problem when there's not so we
typically need to combine both things a
proportion at one and an absolute
deviation from expectation when we do
that we never to get boundary cases so
here we've identified you know the ones
that are very obviously wrong but what
about the ones I've identified in orange
they're a little bit they're a little
bit away from the orange lines that you
can't see honestly but are they far
enough away who knows so you know a
typical example for something like this
were the sorts of numbers we had on the
previous slide might be that we're going
to classify something as an outlier if
the actual value is larger than expected
by at least 50 percent or by at least
150 and so this is you know in an hour
or whatever or if it's lower than
expected by at least a third
and by at least 150 and I'm gonna say
there are no general rules for choosing
limits there or a different way of
saying the same thing would be there are
as many rules for choosing limits as you
want but at the end of the day it always
comes down to comes down to judgement so
we end up looking at historical problems
and setting limits and looking at how
fast it goes off and when it's going off
too much we turn it down a bit and when
it's not going off enough we we turn it
up a bit and then but then we stop there
typically so what we end up if we do
that is effectively saying here's our
actual pattern and we've got some upper
limit we're willing to accept that we've
got some lower limit but they're scaled
and that was clever there's the solution
to the exercise how you calculate those
I guess those are those are simple
enough we probably would have wanted to
do that I think there's an exercise
coming someone turns out that detects
all sorts of things that you would
undoubtly say looking at them yeah I
mean it's so marching on 150 was so
arbitrary we don't really want to detect
that but the trouble is that's not to do
with the magic number 150 because if we
pick 155 it would just have been a
different marginal set there are always
marginal cases it does emphasize that a
useful thing to do is not only to have a
binary detector but to have something
that tells you you know how much does
this breach for limits by so you can at
least prioritize things for the ones
that are miles above the ones that are
miles below but but you're still always
going to end up with the detectors going
off when you don't want them to and also
missing cases that actually you know
there are no there are no perfect
solution is yes
I don't know whether you missed it maybe
maybe I slightly forgot to say it where
we get the expected value from is by
looking at history so typically if we're
you know so in this case literally all
we're doing is if we're looking at you
know we just look back over three months
or six months or a year or whatever
period we need to establish the norm and
literally just calculate on an
hour-by-hour basis first of all over a
day what's the typical pattern for the
day and then if we're interested in
weekly trends we also calculate it on a
on a per week trend and then we either
depending on whether we think the two
effects are multiplicative or not we
either separately compute for each day
what is the average over say the last
six months for Saturday's each hour of
the day or if we think that the patterns
are pretty much the same but scale day
by day we can potentially better
slightly more useful value by computing
a you know a daily pattern and just
scaling it by the the the day of the
week pattern separately sorry you're
quite right I should have said that so
make sense so that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what happened
here
so so if we calculate the obvious limit
just by multiplying by one and a half
and adding a hundred and fifty and
taking the higher of those to get the
maximum and taking the law of the other
two to get the minimum and capping it at
zero this is what this is what gets
detected I'm hoping there's an exercise
coming up soon there is so that's that
that's the sort of graphical approach
but what again is quite interesting is
to go through and actually try writing a
detector that calculates that it's not
particularly hard but it's quite
interesting so if you think was just one
version of the exercise this time if you
start from exercise to dot Pi which is
probably in the directory with a long
helpful name like norm hour day I would
guess there's some there's some starter
code there that you should be able to ID
yourself right the upper and lower
definitions or just take them out of the
earlier slides and then oh no this is
this is for plotting the graph actually
yes so the idea is given starter code
that plots the actual of us expected
versus expected graph can we can we plot
this graph in matplotlib which should
yet which should produce this this graph
here and again there are hints in hints
to dot txt in that directory and then
the third exercise that you can move
straight on to if you get to that is
doing it algorithmically I actually
pulling out the outliers rather than
just plotting the graph so again we're
getting towards the end which is good so
that's that's really what I'm gonna
leave you with if you want to work
through it now by all means do all stick
around the while if you want to look at
afterwards that's fine or just got the
general idea and can't really be
bothered with coding it that's fine too
we have libraries to help you so
I will stick around and help anyone
who's stuck but that's really what I
want to discover today I hope that's
been useful I would be very interested
in feedback obviously as I say this was
set up initially for an online course
which is why you can see some of the
exercises are very much about just
coding stuff but I hope the concepts
used and I hope you'll find the library
useful and that it gives you some feel
generally for how long a dissection can
work
[Applause]
[Music]